[Musique]
bonsoir alors qu'il ait le couvre-feu
est toujours en vigueur mais quelque
chose a changé aujourd'hui parce que
pour sortir dans la journée il n'y a
plus besoin d'attestation c'est la
première étape du début du confinement
en france et ça va s'étaler comme ça
jusqu'à fin juin
avec l'espoir que la vie reprenne et la
vie économique surtout parce que plus le
temps passe plus il ya de risques de
voir des entreprises ne pas pouvoir
relever la tête et des milliers de
personnes perdent leur emploi
c'est une autre course contre la montre
qui est donc engagée la vaccination
permettra peut-être d'accélérer le
rythme
notre invité ce soir dans l'édition
publique le rendez vous politique chaque
lundi soir sur lcp public sénat avec le
figaro et philippe martinez bonsoir
notre bonheur général de la cgt la cgt
qui a été malmené lors du défilé du 1er
mai à paris samedi
il ya des adhérents de votre syndicat
qui ont été prises à partie par un
groupe toujours pas identifiés à ce jour
une enquête est ouverte est-ce que de
votre côté vous avez mener votre enquête
est ce que vous avez des soupçons de qui
est à l'origine de cette attaque
oui oui évidemment on a eu beaucoup d
images qui tournent sur les réseaux
sociaux journalistes ont fait leur
boulot et donc n'a pas identifiés mais
on voit première montre la grande
violence c'est pas molesté c'est une
grande violence on a je vous rappelle on
a 21 blessés et quatre ont été
hospitalisés pourtant mais c'est ça
ressemble beaucoup à l'extrême droite
pour être très clair avec des choses
très organisés où on attaque et puis
après on renvoie devant d'autres
personnes qui sont pas forcément
identifié qu'est ce qui vous fait dire
ça ressemble à l'extrême droite c'est
aussi les propos montée pour danser ou
les propos des propos
qui ont été prononcés les insultes et
quand vous dites extrêmes droites
particulièrement une organisation je
vous dis je ne connais pas et je dis ça
ressemble pour vous pourquoi est ce que
la cgt a été prise pour cible parce que
je pense que nos déclarations sur par
exemple la pétition qui a été fait par
des généraux des armées où nous avons
dénoncé fermement ce qui a été fait
notre combat pour les travailleurs sans
papiers pendant à l'arrivée sur le
cortège c'est une les yvelines union
département des yvelines
il ya beaucoup étaient molles été
attaqué il se trouve qu'il y avait un
grand cortège de travailleurs sans
papiers a lyon par exemple
en début de manifestation même chose
avec des livreurs un vélo qui sont
syndiqués à la cgt est derrière des
travailleurs sans papiers
c'est même des actions qu concertée que
vous évoquez là ah oui c'est pour qu'on
en arrive à un tel niveau s'il ya cia de
la préparation de la préparation on va
aller plus loin maintenant avec brigitte
boucher de laisser tes bons soirs brésil
nos enfants si ça ne traduit de public
sénat bonsoir tabac ravi pour lui après
quelques semaines d'absence tam et oui
on va continuer à parler de ces
violences un de samedi vous avez annoncé
que vous allez porter plainte il ya eu
une réunion aujourd'hui la cgt
à la suite de ces violences à ce que
vous nous le confirmer bien pour
l'instant il ya
le parquet a ouvert une enquête et donc
on doit attendre de voir quelle enquête
et sur quoi est basée cette enquête
est ce que ça ne concerne les violences
et l'agression contre les militantes et
les militants de la cgt ou cet autre
chose et puis on va regarder parce qu'il
ya eu des blessés graves et donc on va
regarder juridiquement est ce qu'il est
possible de faire parce qu'on ne peut
pas tolérer de telles choses dans une
manifestation sociale
vous n'êtes pas encore sûr de pouvoir
porter plein de temps qu'il ya cette
enquête qui est ouverte
on est en train de l'étudier
juridiquement les possibilités mais je
pense qu'on fait confiance à la justice
pour l'instant c'est le parquet donc
tant qu'on ne sait pas ce sur quoi le
parquet enquête
évidemment on attend vous avez attaqué à
la préfecture et les forces de l'ordre
en disant qu'il y avait eu une mauvaise
organisation ou leur demander des
comptes
j'ai évoqué les faits
premièrement du côté de saint-ambroise
il ya eu la manifestation a été stoppée
et des exactions en dehors des cortèges
comme d'habitude et la police ananas et
cerner le carré de tête où je me trouve
de façon pas tout pas normal quoi c'est
ma normal que ça se passe comme ça et en
fin de manifestation oui je le redis
alors que d'habitude toujours en fin de
manifestation il ya une sortie de prévue
pour les manifestants les véhicules
cette sortie était bloqué lisicki
certains véhicules se sont trompés 1
vous savez on est un petit peu idiot à
la cgt mais on sait lire les noms de
rues oui et donc cette sortie était
bloquée et donc c'est bien des ordres
vous accuser nommément d'ailleurs didier
lallement préfet qui commande la police
à paris voilà je précise d'ailleurs que
au moment où c'était à 15h50 au moment
où on était menacée dans le boulevard
voltaire
j'ai envoyé un sms au ministre de
l'intérieur pour lui dire qu'est ce que
c'est que ce qu'est ce qui se passe quoi
et j'attends toujours la réponse
d'ailleurs j'attends toujours une
réaction ou un appel d'un membre du
gouvernement pour ne dire mais ça veut
dire quoi qu'avec des ordres du
ministère de l'intérieur
c'est pas moi qui le jeu non j'ai une
question moi je vous raconte des faits
et les forces de l'ordre
elles ont mis ça à des supérieurs vous
regretté que le gouvernement n'ait pas
réagi pour condamner bien sûr déjà et
puis pour qu'il y ait des explications
sur le fait que cette sortie c'était une
souricière
certes quand vous êtes agressé et que
vous avez plus de deux sorties avec des
forces de l'ordre pied qui regarde parce
que qu'ils regardent ce qui se passe eh
bien il ya un problème non double
échelle des restaurateurs au monde
jusqu'à gérald darmanin des ja à paris
on préfère et puis ces jeux
me semble qu'il ya un ministre en
expliquant que la police finalement et
la première fautive
est-ce que vous n'exonérait pas exonérer
pas un peu vite ce que vous accusez ou
les black blocks où les gilet jaune je
je je crois que vous n'avez pas bien
écouté j'ai la première responsabilité
c'est et je les ai cité des franges
d'extrême droite qui ont agressé
physiquement violemment en fait il ya
nos camarades qui étaient hospitalisés
qui a perdu connaissance et aujourd'hui
ils vont tous bien
il vaut mieux mais il faut les suivre
médicalement parce que quand on a perdu
connaissance ou savez il peut y avoir
des répercussions quelques jours quelque
chose aura presque voilà ce que je dis
et jeudi deuxièmement que ce n'est ce
qui là là là ce qui s'est passé pendant
et après du côté de ceux qui donnent des
ordres policiers ce n'est pas normal
alors on va aller au delà qui peut
déférer jeunes avaient du coup qu'est ce
que vous demandez pour mieux sécuriser
ces manifestations qui depuis maintenant
pas mal de temps connaissent ce genre de
des braillements déjà sur la fin de la
manifestation il faut que ce qui est
prévu pour évacuer la manifestation ça
doit se faire de façon fluide des cas un
arrêt surtout à la place de la nation il
y avait beaucoup de monde peut-être
certains qu'ils aient jamais plus
globalement pour l'ensemble des
manifestations qu'est ce que vous
demandez comme mesures qui doivent être
prises que ceux qui ne viennent pas
manifester des slogans pour des slogans
sociaux des revendications et bien ne
puisse pas avoir des exactions tels que
nous en avons connu et donc je suis
arrivé à la manifestation c'est une
anecdote mais que je suis arrivé à la
manifestation pour les parisiens du côté
du ciel d'hiver long du boulevard
beaumarchais je suis descendu de la
voiture j'ai on m'a demandé mes papiers
la police m'a demandé mes papiers et ont
demandé à fouiller ce qui était avec moi
je dis tiens donc il y avait une
sécurisation de la manifestation pour le
secrétaire-général mais pas pour les
patrons
manifestation avec des barres de fer
avec des bouteilles en verre
j'ai un masque moi quand je vais aux
manifestations il y à il ya plusieurs la
sécurité qui ont été votées et
dernièrement la loi sur la sécurité
globale qui vient d'être définitivement
adopté une loi contre laquelle vous vous
êtes quand même assez fortement
mobilisés et qui prévoit par exemple
l'utilisation de drones de surveillance
pourquoi pas dans les manifestations
finalement est-ce que c'est pas une
bonne idée c'est toi de sécurité non
c'est pas une bonne idée parce que ça
remet en cause
globalement les libertés individuelles
et collectives avec des possibilités de
d'arrestations arbitraires etc
donc c'est pas les ça empêcherait
peut-être ces personnes qui est un film
sur les manifestations des lois il y en
a beaucoup déjà et c'est le 3e 1er mai
de suite si on met de côté celui de
l'année dernière où il ya des choses qui
se passent et qui sont pas normales des
lois il y en a déjà
donc c'est inefficace voilà la preuve
une table oui parmi les raisons pour
lesquelles vous manifestiez il ya la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui doit
entrer en vigueur le 1er juillet
prochain
est ce que vous prévoyez d'autres
journées d'action précisément sur ce
thème sur l'assurance chômage sur ce sur
ce thème et bien d'autres je pense qu'on
aura l'occasion d'en parler
oui oui c'est cette réforme elle
symbolise tout ce que tout le contraire
de ce qu'il faut faire dans ce pays
c'est à dire qu'on va il ya un million
sept cent mille personnes qui sont
concernées et qui vont voir soit leur
droits réduits soit leur droits
supprimer 1 million 700 mille personnes
parmi celles ci des femmes en congé
maternité des personnes en arrêt maladie
il ya besoin que le quoi qu'il en coûte
ils servent à ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin est-ce qu'il ya pas aussi des
mesures dans cette réforme comme le
plafonnement la dégressivité des
indemnités des plus hauts revenus ou
encore la taxation des contrats courts
des points sur lesquels vous êtes
d'accord tout n'est pas à jeter dans la
réforme
premièrement
je ne vois pas pourquoi on plafonne ray
les indemnités en fonction des salaires
deuxièmement les plus aisés s'avoue
enfin moi je moi je suis pour qu'on
rétablisse l'impôt sur la fortune si on
veut parler des plus aisés par exemple
parce que là on est dans une autre
catégorie or eux ils ont eu des cadeaux
il faut un cadre supérieur mais ils
gagnent plus que d'autres mais il est
pas un milliardaire où est ce que je
veux dire rétablissons l'impôt sur la
fortune pour remettre de l'argent dans
pour le bien commun localisation des
contrats courts par exemple acheter
enfin nous on est pour parce que ces
bonus malus des bonus les grandes
entreprises en ont plein donc nous on
est pour un malus mais je vous signale
que la réforme s'applique au 1er juillet
pour diminuer les indemnités pour le
bonus malus c'est à la fin de l'année
2022 me semble-t-il c'est ça alors il ya
une autre réforme qui est celle des
retraites qui est dans la feuille de
route que la france a transmises à
bruxelles en tant que partenaires
sociaux est ce que le gouvernement vous
a confirmé que cette réforme des
retraites aurait bien lieu
non non non non enfin on entend des
ministres sur le maire est un adepte
cette réforme d'autres évitent d'en
parler j'ai cru comprendre qu'il ya eu
deux documents fournis à la commission
de bruxelles en dix pages
et puis un autre de 80 pages ans n'a pas
analysé les 80 pages mais j'ai cru
comprendre que ça faisait partie des
promesses en tout cas qu'on donnait à
londres elle en serait pour pour avoir
donc vous pensez qu'elle peut avoir lieu
d'ici la fin du jeu pense que le pays
est très en colère
prêt pour diverses raisons je pense que
soit gouvernement a compris le message
de la mobilisation du printemps la fin
de l'hiver 2019-2020 même et soit il
continue à jeter de l'huile sur le feu
c'est comme pour l'assurance chômage
quand toutes les confédérations
syndicales en france sont contre quelque
chose c'est rare donc vous mettez en
garde le gouvernement mais c'est rare ça
devrait être un peu mieux pris en compte
cette réforme elle a aussi pour objectif
de réduire les déficits
qu'est ce que vous vous proposez du coup
pour réduire ses déficits
on mélange tout on mélange tout on parle
de dettes déficits yahia il ya deux
choses différentes ya l'utilisation des
impôts des citoyens la dette la dette il
faut l'analyser en aurons la dette elle
a été générée par la crise financière de
2007 2010 2008 émérite elle est générée
aussi par la crise que nous vivons
aujourd'hui donc est ce que l'argent qui
a été dépensé alors pas en 2008 parce
que s'attaque directement aux banques
mais là est ce que c'est bien ou c'est
pas bien d'aider les gens nous on pense
que c'est bien autre chose aides sont
les les recettes de la sécurité sociale
parce que quand on parle retraite
assurance chômage c'est la sécurité
sociale vous savez quand on ferme le
robinet de la baignoire et sculptures or
on a une politique d'exonération de
cotisations sociales notamment des
grandes entreprises
de plus en plus et ben il ya pire est
qu'il faut aller chercher l'argent
oui bien sûr parce que notre modèle
social il est
il est utile bien il est utile alors on
va aller maintenant
là je disais tout à l'heure en ouvrant
cette émission que ça y est le défi
confinement commence et il y avait
urgence d'ailleurs là certains points
véritable et oui emmanuel macron dit qu
il faut vivre désormais avec le virus et
que l'économie notamment doit repartir
vous voyez vous les entreprises qui
ferment le chômage qui va exploser
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec lui
sur sa tombe mais le message que
l'économie doit vivre je l'entends
depuis 14 mois non vous êtes d'accord
avec ça je l'entends depuis 14 mois
est-ce qu'on va finir donc c'est pas
nouveau comme discours sur le maire il a
toujours dit ça attention l'économie etc
on a confiné et là ont des consignes oui
alors il faut des confits n'est
évidemment pas ce qu'on peut pas vu
comme ça mais vous avez en tout cas moi
j'ai croisé le président de la
république jeudi dernier on dit on donne
des dates mais derrière il ya des si et
vous savez que la communauté
scientifique médical est dubitative
seulement qu'on puisse dire il faut
aussi la pire des choses ce serait de
s'engager sur des dates et que le moment
venu la 4e confinement je n'imaginais
même pas dans quel état d'esprit on
serait tous et toutes
donc il faut le faire quelles que soient
les conditions pour être sûr tambours et
puis faire en sorte que toutes les
précautions soient prises et je constate
qu'il ya des problèmes pour la
vaccination pour les tests les autotests
etc sont pas des écoles il ya des
consignes sont claires alors là c'est
très bien en théorie c'est parfait puis
quand vous discutez avec les enseignants
peut-être des enfants qui vont à l'école
c'est un peu plus compliqué oui donc
c'est ça c'est ce décalage entre les
discours et puis des réalités qui
peuvent être autres on va parler de la
vaccination
mais tout d'abord les faillites ont été
limités grâce aux aides de l'état à ce
que vous craignez des plans sociaux en
cascade une fois et bien que ces aides
cesseront et dans quel secteur vous avez
mais aujourd'hui il y en a déjà beaucoup
on est licenciements mais on sait qu'il
va y en avoir certainement encore mais
dans une plus
chamakh avait raison il ya des aides et
en même temps il ya des entreprises qui
licencient
est ce que est ce que c'est normal c'est
pour ça qu'on en demande que de
conditionner ses aides et qu'elle soit
transparente
à quoi ça sert moi je conditionne à quoi
vous avez des êtres vous ne vous sentiez
pas c'est qu'il ya beaucoup moins de
faillites que mais allez dire ça à
quelqu'un qui perd son boulot
tiens je cite souvent un grand hôtel
parler on parlera peut-être industrie
tout à l'heure un grand hôtel opéra 25%
du personnel licencié alors qu'eux ils
ont ils des aides le la direction à vis
des aides sur le chômage partiel parce
que le chômage partiel cdz 100 % pour
les entreprises
84 % pour les salariés et puis ils ont
eu des z
parce que comme auront eu tout tout tout
tout l'industrie du tourisme et puis
derrière c'est un plan social par un
plan de restructuration des
licenciements à eux on leur dit oui mais
vous comprenez il y en a eu au moins que
prévu
non non il faut il faut les aides mais
ce qui aurait peut-être y jette alors
justement avant les voir ils ont pas
avec les années ils sont en train de
tout moderniser eelv ont externalisé ils
vont casser les statuts mais on pourrait
on pourra parler des fonderies si vous
voulez aux élèves le maire le ministre
de l'économie francis a annoncé le
maintien des aides pour les
restaurateurs les salles de spectacles
tous ceux qui rouvriront le 19 mai qui
ne pourront pas et bien retrouvé leur
chiffre d'affaires total donc même sous
les 50%
est ce que ça vous semble suffisamment
incitatif justement pour qu'il rouvre
mais c'est très bien ça je joue dit nous
on n'est pas contre les aides aux
entreprises
mais on veut savoir à quoi elles servent
et je pense notamment aux petits
commerçants au restaurant vous savez
quand on va ouvrir quand j'ai cru
comprendre quand on a une terrasse qui
représentent que 10 % de la clientèle ne
d'habitude et ben il faut compenser mais
il faut aussi penser aux salariés je
vous le répète il ya des salariés qui
depuis 14 mois touche 84 % de leur
salaire
comme disait quelqu'un quand on n'arrive
pas à finir à boucler le mois au bout du
troisième jour d'un canton à 84%
c'est encore moins alors il ya aussi la
prime mâcon qui a été
reconduite pour la troisième année
consécutive offert et 2000 euros est ce
que vous demandez aux gouvernements
qu'ils se soient plus incitatif et que
les entreprises s'en empare mais quand
on annonce quelque chose donc ça soit
obligatoire sinon c'est de la
communication parce que pour
premièrement la première peu peu en
touche et c'était 1000 euros la première
peut on touche et 1000 euros avec
intéressement jusqu'à 2000 euros peu en
touche et 1000 euros la moyenne je crois
que c'est 475 comme ça donc déjà on est
très loin des 1000 et puis c'est au bon
vouloir de deux des directions
d'entreprises meilleurs que je vais dire
que les notes de frais avant d
éventuellement financièrement mais mais
mais mais mais conditionnée aux aides et
mais premièrement l'état n'a pas mais
les la meilleure chose qui puisse
arriver par exemple pour les salariés
deuxième ligne c'est que leurs salaires
soient augmentés
ça c'est pas si si le patron jeu ou pas
c'est pas une fois dans l'année c'est
tous les mois c'est la même chose on a
beaucoup parlé des salariés deuxième
ligne ils sont payés comme art ils sont
payés comme avant et pourtant qu'est ce
qu'on qu'est ce qu'on leur a fait comme
loges à juste titre mais vous savez on
peut leur distribuer des bons points ça
les aidera pas aller à manger à élever
leurs enfants etc
et là on va parler de vaccins on va pas
de la vaccination tout d'abord geoffroy
roux de bézieux et laurent berger lancé
un appel pour accélérer la vaccination
en entreprise vous les suivez
il faut que enfin en entreprise comme
ailleurs il faut que ça soit par contre
faut que ça soit organisée moi j'ai
demandé justement j'en ai parlé lors
cette réunion avec le président de la
république la semaine dernière jeudi
premièrement pour la vaccination tout le
monde devrait avoir au moins une
demi-journée payer pour aller se faire
vacciner
ça c'est votre proposition c'est la
position que vous avez fait des
propositions de la cgt oui parce que le
monde du temps d'aller en centre de
vaccination à la fois on attend
longtemps
donc et qui il faut il faut par exemple
qui est plus de bus style de médecine du
travail qui aillent dans les zones
commerciales dans les zones où il ya des
salariés pour éviter les déplacements
selon vous rejoignez cet appel de
geoffroy roux de bézieux laurent berger
pense qu'ils m'ont écouté jeudi dernier
ils sont d'accord avec moi je ne sais
pas si monsieur roux de bézieux d'accord
pour payer pour payer une demi journée
il m'a écouté qu'une partie de ma
proposition
voilà les métiers les plus exposés
désormais en droit aux vaccins
lorsqu'ils ont plus de 55 ans par
exemple d'un enseignant petite enfance
caissier et c'est à ce qu' il faut
l'étendre pour vous sans limite d'âge
aujourd'hui bien sûr bien sûr il faut
l'étendre skip l'eau le problème c'est
la gestion des vaccins il faut l'étendre
vous allez dire un enseignant qui a 55
ans trois mois et est celui qui a 54 ans
n'y a pas le droit ils ont les mêmes
conditions de travail et puis le
personnel les atsem et c'est donc oui il
faut le le problème c'est que on nous
dit qu'il ya beaucoup de vaccins et en
même temps ils ne crient pas encore
assez il y en a peut-être pas encore
exactement et on va terminer avec une
question 2 de brigitte sur bridgestone
qui a beaucoup fait l'actualité encore
will usine de pneumatiques et à qui a
fermé 500 personnes aujourd'hui n'ont
pas retrouvé d'emploi sur les 800 et la
secrétaire d'état à l'industrie en
espagne heures une hache et annoncé
qu'il y avait neuf projets qui était
dans les tiroirs pour que ces personnes
justement retrouver un emploi est ce que
vous vous êtes optimiste des projets on
a beaucoup parlé ministre on parle
beaucoup moi ce que je vois c'est qu'il
ya des salariés qui sont virés quoi dans
une entreprise qui a délocalisé dans
l'est de l'europe
donc on qui va un groupe qui va
continuer à faire des petits e mail les
pneus mais ailleurs et qui va exploiter
des salariés d'autres pays dans l'union
européenne dans l'union européenne c'est
pour ça que nous revendiquons par
exemple un salaire minimum à l'échelle
de l'europe pour éviter le dumping
social vous voyez pas avec des salariés
de l'autre bout du monde au sein de
l'union voilà des mesures qui devraient
pourtant tout cas social à porto cette
semaine ça prouve quand même que l'état
suit bridgestone de très près non mais
vous savez il suffit surtout je peux la
touche
chez qui suivent tous moi ce que nous ce
qu'on veut c'est des résultats parce que
quelqu'un qui se fait licencier
on peut lui parler de notre projet lui
pour l'instant je n'y croyais pas à ses
projets mais c'est pas que j'y crois pas
moi je vous les a mises en voix
je crois ce que je vois et
malheureusement dans beaucoup
d'entreprises
on promet on promet et puis il ya
toujours du monde sur le carreau donc
toutes les belles phrases relocalisation
localisation développement de
l'industrie pour l'instant moi j'entends
beaucoup de fermetures d'entreprises
industrielles et un état qui dit mais
vous inquiétez pas il y en a que 60 % de
licenciés à tel endroit ne vous
inquiétez pas on en a quand même sauvé
20 % c'est pas ça un projet un plan de
relance c'est un projet ambitieux pour
l'industrie française
merci brigitte et à ses principes et à
lundi soir l'automobile savez cet ordre
que vous connaissez vous est réveillé
chez renault les 350 salariés de la
fonderie de bretagne à caudan dans le
morbihan s'inquiètent ils ont occupé
leur usine parce que renault veut
séparer de cette usine mais d'autres
fonderies automobiles sont en difficulté
en meurthe et moselle dans le jura en
aveyron dans la vienne d'ici les dix ans
qui viennent il pourrait même y avoir
plus de 5000 emplois menacés dans ce
secteur en partie à cause des
localisations mais aussi les besoins de
l'industrie qui change
alors est ce qu'il est possible à vos
yeux de maintenir ses productions oui
oui très clairement parce que on
premièrement ces fonderies elle fabrique
elle fabrique des pièces essentielles
des moteurs il ya beaucoup de débats sur
la motorisation électrique
si on prend l'ensemble des motorisations
électriques il ya deux sujets il ya les
moteurs complètement électrique est ce
qu'on appelle les hybrides rechargeables
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un hybride
rechargeable
c'est un moteur électrique et un moteur
thermique à moteur thermique et bien il
faut que des pièces de fonderie
or c'est un secteur motorisation qui
augmente mais dans le volume de ses
moteurs vendu 65 % sont des hybrides
rechargeables c'est à dire 65 % ont des
moteurs thermiques
donc tout cela avec franck et peuvent
élever dans une fonderie
ils sont faits aujourd'hui devrait
continuer ce que je constate moi c'est
que malgré les aides on en parlait tout
à l'heure
malgré
les discours gouvernementaux des
entreprises comme renault ou peugeot
renault où l'état je vous le rappelle
est le premier actionnaire est bien
continuer à dire eh ben on va aller à
fabriquer à l'autre bout de leurs hommes
parce que coup compétitivité etc
avec quelles conséquences premièrement
des salariés qui sont travaillés dans
des mauvaises conditions
deuxièmement il faudrait vérifier les
coûts économiques parce que quand on
rallonge la distance les coûts de
transport sans plus cher et puis la
planète dont on parle beaucoup plus en
rapport
on rapporte des pièces de très loin en
camion plus la planète souffre donc
c'est à dire que l'on va faire
on nous dit faut vendre les voitures
électriques mais on va on augmente les
distances et la planète en prendre un
coup juste dernière chose en france 43 %
du parc automobile 43%
ce sont des voitures avec des vignettes
critères 3 4 5 c'est à dire l'europe en
cas de pollution pratiquement une
voiture sur deux en france ne put pu
circuler il ya peut-être besoin de
renouveler ce parc automobile qu'est ce
qui bloque les gens qui bat scellier
pose problème de pouvoir d'achat parce
que les voitures ça coûte cher ou des z
pour changer c'est surtout pour faire
vivre les fonderies par exor mais à
condition que on équilibre les emplois
en france avec les emplois nous on n'est
pas contre le fait que d'autres
travailleurs et du boulot c'est pas ça
mais que les règles du jeu soient les
mêmes bons fois yves thréard bonsoir
pensive éditorialistes et directeur
adjoint du figaro qui est en face de
vous pour quelques minutes
bonsoir fils est parti hier soir je vous
écoute est tout à l'heure vous disiez
que le pays était en colère ce qui est
assez juste
et comment vous expliquez que vous
syndicats c'était votre fonction de
canaliser cette colère est aujourd'hui
bah on al'impression vous n'avez plus la
main vous n'avez plus la maîtrise de
tout cela est d'ailleurs le nombre de
vos adhérents baisse considérablement
depuis pas mal d'années 600000 je crois
autour de 600 milles
faire une bataille de chiffres
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi les syndicats
et vous notamment qui est quand même été
longtemps le premier syndicat en france
n'arrivait plus à canaliser cette colère
qui n'est pas uniquement sociales
d'ailleurs je le reconnais je le
reconnais premièrement j'ai évidemment
je serai plus mesuré que vous sur les
appréciations les fonderies que sur les
télés a cité c'est la cgt qui canalise
la colère pour reprendre vos propos on
est présent etc
mais moi je ne nie pas que nous avons
discuté
je pense que le monde du travail a
évolué plus vite que les syndicats que
notre façon de raisonner
j'en conviens et aimer mais on est en
train de faire des choses intéressantes
par exemple on vient de conte et en est
à douze syndicats de livres à vélo c'est
à dire d'aider les nouvelles formes de
travail parce qu'on se rend compte que
en les écoutant ils ont besoin de
garanties collectives donc il faut que
le syndicalisme ils prennent mieux en
compte la diversité du modéré il a mis
trop de temps se moderniser parce
moderniser prendre en compte à quel
point le travail à bouger et et je moi
je dis souvent on peut être contre le
travail du dimanche et nous sommes
contre le travail du dimanche c'est pas
pour ça qu'il faut culpabiliser ceux qui
travaillent le dimanche parce que shaw
qui bouffe
alors ya d'autres soucis aussi c'est
qu'en france les syndicats sont divisés
on l'a encore vu au 1er mai la cfdt
n'était pas dans vos rangs ou à côté de
vous est ce que on a le sentiment que
d'un côté il ya les réformateurs
puis l'autre côté des syndicats comme la
cgt qui sont un peu plus contestataire
est-ce que c'est pas comme les partis
politiques finalement qui sont aussi
d'ailleurs dépassé par les événements
avec deux gauches irréconciliables de
droite on a vu ce week-end
irréconciliables et pourquoi pas non
plus peut-être des syndicats qui sont
irréconciliables
je ne pense pas si on reste évidemment
il ya de la division syndicale et angers
à chaque fois qu'il ya de la division
syndicale
c'est pas bon pour le monde du travail
on a certainement à mieux travailler ce
qui nous
rassemble j'évoquais tout à l'heure que
nous portons ensemble tous les syndicats
français l'idée d'un salaire minimum en
europe et on le porte avec d'autres
comment on travaille plus sur ce qui
nous rassemble
après nous avons des idées différentes
et tout le monde le sait moi je conteste
le fait que ray les réformistes et les
contestataires ou les modernes et les
archaïques la cgt à la plante
propositions mais on a une vision de la
société qui est de plus en plus
différentes c'est vrai contrairement à
ce que vous soyez des cas laurent berger
par exemple je viens de vous dire qu ont
porté ensemble l'idée d'un salaire
minimum européen et vous me dites que
vous avez une vision différente mais
mais sur un certain nombre de choses on
a deux visions différentes parquet ce
qui est irréconciliable par exemple
juste non je dirais pas héros
conciliables il faut il est quoi par
exemple qu'est-ce qui le plumard gens je
pense faire la différence par exemple
c'est que la cfdt considère que tout
doit se passer à l'entreprise y compris
et et nous nous pensons que ce qu'on
appelle la hiérarchie des normes doit
être trouvé c'est à dire qu'il ya un
code du travail
il ya des conventions collectives qui ne
peuvent pas être en dessous du code du
travail que dans les entreprises
il peut y avoir des accords d'entreprise
supérieurs parce que si on ne scie on
n'a pas des règles comme ça et bien
c'est un peu la loi de la jungle dans
une boîte dans la même rue qui fabrique
le même produit bas on va avoir des
statuts différents
bon ça c'est une différence importante
entre nous alors je vous ai suivis
pendant la campagne électorale de 2017
je sais pour qui vous avez voté c'est un
secret pour personne le très fort et je
vous ai pas vu dans l'isoloir avec moi
non mais vous l'avez dit vous-même
non je n'ai jamais dit et j'ai rien dis
ah bon monsieur mélenchon de la france
insoumise et candidat mais monsieur
fabien roussel du parti communiste kke
et le le patron du parti communiste a
affiché aussi sa candidature il allait
voir un dilemme pour vous comment la cgt
peu et philippe martinez va se
positionner par rapport à ça
je crois qu'il y en a d'autres qui sont
candidats oui ou prétendant ou prétendus
j'en sais rien vous savez nous ce qu'on
demande nos premièrement on considère
qu' il faut pas attendre 2022 pour se
mobiliser pour porter les revendications
et il faut que ceux qui prétendent
qu'ils sont les représentants du monde
ouvrier du monde du travail prennent
mieux en compte les réalités du monde du
travail donc la cgt ça va être un scoop
pour vous n'aura pas de candidat en 2022
aux présidentielles et donc la cgt elle
continuera à oeuvrer pour que ce sur
quoi nous nous battons au quotidien avec
les salariés bien puisse émerger dans un
programme dans des programmes je ne sais
pas voilà quant à l'idée d'aider des
combats que vous menez est ce que ça
vous désole pas de voir que la gauche
est en miettes quoi elle était
complètement effrité je vois je ce sont
des combats communs quand même notamment
salaires notamment conditions de travail
notamment
peut-être aussi respect de l'écologie et
l'environnement
mais oui mais je moi je me désole que
retour de l' isf
oui je me désole que au son au quotidien
ou sur un certain nombre de sujets il
n'y ait pas plus de deux voix commune
qui porte les aspirations des salariés
je me je me désole que sur les questions
du travail on ne soit pas mieux entendus
sur l'évolution du travail sur sur les
mauvaises conditions de travail
est-ce que vous désole que la gauche a
divisé sa demande le nom mais j'ai bien
compris la question mais c'est ça mais
j'ai désolé ou pas mais je je je je je
pense que sur cette question là c'est
pas du ressort de la cgtr est ce qui a
peut-être une explication il ya une
étude cevipof très très bien mené qui a
été
publiée récemment qui montre que
notamment les jeunes qui ont moins de 35
ans et bien ses jeunes vont être actif
actif vote plutôt pour le rassemblement
national
est-ce que c'est pas un souci ça ah ben
c'est plus qu'un souci c'est plus qu'un
souci pas ça veut dire qu'il n'adhère
pas chez vous non plus enfin vous
mélangez tout vous de mélange dans c'est
pas la même chose à dire aux syndicats
aient voté pour le principe est adhérent
de la cgt est votée rassemblement
national contrairement à vous je vais
pas dans l'isoloir et donc je ne vérifie
pas que votre les adhérents par contre
on a un vrai travail d'explication sur
le la réalité est le vrai et le
programme économique et social du front
national ce sont des usurpateurs
on peut pas demander la retraite à 60
ans et demander la suppression des
cotisations sociales ans dans notre pays
ça marche pas comme ça
donc voilà après oui il ya eu beaucoup
de désillusions notamment après les
gouvernements go j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire
les deux fois où un le pen est une le
pen sont arrivés au deuxième tour 7 est
à la suite de gouvernements de gauche
lionel jospin françois hollande et donc
des promesses non tenues ça c'est que
dans des régions dévastées par la case
de l'industrie eh bien ça donne des gens
qui disent bas on te pu les croire il
faut peut-être essayer autre chose et
c'est là qu'a commencé peut-être avant
tout le monde c'était il ya 40 ans il
s'appelait françois mitterrand et
c'était avec lui d'ailleurs que le front
national commencé à progresser dans les
dents les élections françois mitterrand
c'était il ya quarante ans le 10 mai
avec des réformes les 39 heures à
l'épreuve en 2 ans oui en deux ans et 39
là-haut sur la fortune alors face à 60
ans
est ce que finalement tout ça ça va
durer très peu de temps parce que le
pays bas il a il a mal vécu
est-ce que c'est pas lui qui a sonné le
glas du syndicalisme et de la gauche en
tout cas c'est chaque fois que des
promesses sont non tenues aider
notamment des promesses sociales et bien
il ya un retour de manivelle grave
est-ce que ça j'ai confiance en soi y
étaient enserrés savez quand on dit mon
ennemi c'est la finance et qu'on fait
beaucoup de cadeaux aux entreprises
on le paye très cher quand on dit l'état
ne peut pas tout était cas de la série
il est arrivé j'étais défenseur
mitterrand vous le mettez il est arrivé
j'étais délégué central chez renault
c'était au moment de la fermeture de
l'usiné de vilvorde
on nous avait promis de la maintenir et
quand il est arrivé la ferme et donc et
françois mitterrand son héritage vous en
retenez quoi des réformes pendant deux
ans des référés les augmentations de
salaires certainement beaucoup de choses
pour la culture ça c'est en ce moment ça
vaut le coup d'en parler des réformes
sociétales l'abolition de la peine de
mort voilà mais beaucoup beaucoup de
désillusions dans le monde du travail
je m'en souviens j'étais jeune toute
question pour finir vous êtes inquiet
pour l'avenir de ce pays oui je suis
inquiet si on continue comme ça oui je
suis inquiet parce que pour des raisons
que vous avez signalé d'ailleurs parce
que quand les gens ne croient plus en la
politique
quand les gens sont trop en colère et
bien ça ça ça génère des conflits et
parfois des conflits pas toujours à bon
escient donc oui oui je suis inquiet et
puis voir des jeunes sacrifiés le
chômage qui augmente on a de quoi être
inquiet vous savez quand la pauvreté
augmente quand on voit les files dans
les associations caritatives bas on a de
quoi être inquiet oui merci merci
francis fillion tic
vous avez droit de partir quand même et
on prend très ressenti cela comme ça
c'est une image jo maiden nouveau
président américain a fêté ses cent
premiers jours à la tête des états unis
mais moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
certaines de ces mesures décoiffe
vu par les américains même vu par la
france dans son temps avec une taxe sur
le capital qui le pourrait passer à 40 %
c'est-à-dire doublé au dessus de 1
million des taxes aussi sur les actions
taxation des multinationales pour
financer les dépenses publiques les
aides pour mettre en place des projets
d'importance vous applaudissez l'a
écouté ses c'est tout le contraire de ce
qu'on vit ici depuis les américains hier
il ya encore de la marge pour que il
retrouve notre modèle social mais en
tout cas il ya un pays et pas n'importe
le tiennent au monde qui parle de
sécurité sociale de santé de bien commun
etc qui veut taxer les très riches qui
dit il faut remonter l'impôt sur les
sociétés c'est plutôt c'est plutôt que
j'aurais imaginé ça de la part des états
unis vont vous savez il ya un mouvement
syndical à important aux états unis très
important et qui sont sur des bases qui
n'ont rien à envier à la cgt ou au
contraire comme vous voulez voilà il ya
du syndicalisme aux états unis il n'y a
pas que les images qu'on peut voir
parfois dans les médias et maintenant on
accueille les deux parlementaires qui
vont débattre avec vous
bonsoir didier baichère conçoit et vend
soir laurence garnier présenté à par un
didier baichère qui est député la
république en marche des yvelines et
laurence garnier vous êtes sénatrice et
l'air de loire atlantique alors à titre
indicatif
j'indique en plus que didier baichère
vous avez été directeur des ressources
humaines avant d'entrer en politique
c'est ça et que laurence garnier vous
allez travailler dans l'industrie
automobile tout elle va vous parler tout
ça en tout cas ils ont des questions
pour venus chiner question une question
qui va les rejoindre à un moment même si
c'est pas le même angle sur le travail à
distance qui s'est beaucoup développée
avec son collier dès cherche
oui oui je crois que ces douze derniers
mois on a on a vraiment vécu une
révolution de l'organisation du travail
mais je ne veux pas le traité que sous
l'angle du télétravail mais peut-être de
manière contrainte beaucoup de salariés
se sont retrouvés à travailler dans des
conditions qui était pas celle
habituelle à partir le matin elle est
dans une entreprise où aller sur son
lieu de travail et on a découvert
peut-être que beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise ont découvert le travail à
distance et le management à distance
moi je m'interrogeais en fait sur est ce
que finalement les syndicalistes aussi
sont un pendant cette période ont dû
gérer leurs relations de défense des
salariés de manière différente et est-ce
que ça augure quelque chose du
syndicalisme de demain je je me demande
si on maintient ce travail à distance de
manière pérenne pendant longtemps
est-ce qu'il faudra pas aussi inventer
une autre manière de développer la
relation syndicale avec les salariés
c'est évident ce que je veux dire c'est
que le travail à distance n'existe pas
depuis un an et demi première accord
national que la cgt d'ailleurs assignées
c'était 2005 dont vous voyez on ne
découvre pas le travail à distance
ça c'est la première chose par contre
7,7 cette pandémie qui a mis des
millions de travailleurs et
travailleuses en télétravail à faire
venir
moi je l'aidais defarges les apprécier
la notion de travail collectif le besoin
de se voir là nous aurons parle beaucoup
de travail collectif et quand on est
chez soi se voir sur un écran c'est
quand même pas terrible et donc à même
ceux qui étaient en télétravail avant la
pandémie disent ouais mais c'est quand
même bien de se voir au moins deux
fois par semaine discuter des projets
etc donc ça c'est une chose importante
alors évidemment il faut que le
syndicalisme ils prennent en compte donc
on a innové
on a mis en place des numéros verts par
exemple parce que faut aussi penser à
ceux qui sont en télétravail compath
syndicat dans l'entreprise et en a
beaucoup mais on est on est bloqué sur
une chose et puisque vous êtes un ancien
drh vous avez tout de suite qu'on pense
que je veux dire c'est que les
entreprises refusent d'appliquer les
mêmes systèmes pour les syndicats que
pour les salariés
concrètement un aller voir un salarié
sur son lieu de travail va dire bonjour
et c'est allé le voir à la maison par le
telegraph travail c'est pas possible
parce qu'il ya pratiquement aucun accord
d'entreprise de droits syndicaux qui
permet un syndicat de s'adresser
individuellement à un salarié et vice
versa faire qu on nous pose des
questions on peut nous nous posent des
questions sur le par le biais du site ne
peut pas répondre
c'est du domaine privé c'est la
messagerie de l'entreprise on peut pas
parler mais sa séance a en fait que je
m'interrogeais sur la suite parce que si
durablement et on est en fonctionnement
j'avais pense qu'on devrait mettre sur
la table un moment donné mais nous la
refondation de ce dialogue en posant la
question depuis très longtemps dans la
pose et au gouvernement
il faut aimer et aux employeurs il faut
que les accès aux messageries
professionnelles soit libéré pour les
syndicats pour les salariés parce que
quand on a un problème à la maison
et bien c'est compliqué de de s'adresser
au syndicat ouais vous avez un niveau
nous a pour ça il faut des accords
d'entreprise dans les eaux une loi peut
être son pilule yaz faudra une
négociation va être ta mère
professionnelle parce que vous avez des
métiers qui sont très différents faut
des accords d'entreprise mais par
exemple ce n'est pas prévu dans un
accord qui a fait un peu de bruit parce
qu'il est ici n'y a pas longtemps sauf
par la cgt où ce n'est pas prévu ce
n'est pas prévu je voulais prolonger cet
échange sur le télétravail didier
baichère a évoqué un certain nombre
d'aspects moi je voudrais porter auprès
de vous l'idée selon laquelle le
télétravail peut aussi être un
formidable outil pour réduire les
inégalités
je pense que ça va beaucoup vous
intéresser on a aujourd'hui des
inégalités qui fracturent le pays et je
crois que le télétravail peut permettre
de ré
vire à la fois les fractures
territoriales parce qu'il peut permettre
demain évidemment s'il est bien encadré
et c'est là que vous avez votre rôle à
jouer aux côtés des entreprises
d'habiter différemment le territoire et
de permettre peut-être de réinvestir des
zones rurales qui se sentent aujourd'hui
complètement abandonné de l'action
publique est-ce qu'on peut télétravail
et de partout daul exactement et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle on
peut
je pense en faire un levier pour réduire
les inégalités sociales parce qu'on sait
bien que entre celui qui a les moyens de
s'installer à proximité immédiate de son
travail à 5 ou 10 km qui va aller à vélo
rejoindre l'hyper centre-ville de telle
ou telle grande métropole et celui qui
au contraire est contraint parce qu'il
n'a pas cette possibilité de s'installer
à 50,60 parfois 70 km l'inégalité est là
et c'est la france des gilet jaune qu'on
a connu il ya deux ans c'est cette
inégalité qui a nourri cette
exaspération et cette colère donc moi ce
qui m'intéressait c'était de savoir
comment en tant que syndicat vous pouvez
demain accompagner ce développement du
télétravail parce que je crois qu'on est
d'accord on reviendra pas à un travail
telle qu'on l'a connue avant cette crise
sanitaire en tout cas pas de la même
manière comment est ce qu'on peut
trouver les bon curseur et accompagner
le développement pour en faire un outil
de réduction des inégalités
c'est il faut premièrement il faut que
l'autre télétravail soit fait sur la
base du volontariat
c'est important parce que il ya encore
beaucoup de salariés qu'ils subissent
la deuxième chose c'est parler d'égalité
des territoires enfin quand le numérique
sera partout ça ira beaucoup mieux or il
ya encore du boulot si vous vous
permettez
c'est là que l'action publique doit
trouver tout ça le raccordement optique
dans vos collectivités je sais pas si ça
se passe il ya beaucoup de collectivités
combi de l'argent pour avoir la fibre et
qu'ils attendent encore ou qui ont de la
suivre fibres des fayots défaillante
celle qui vient de chine par exemple
parce qu'on n'est pas capable ou on a
ponte c'est plus en fabriquer on ne veut
plus en fabriquer en france
la deux la deuxième chose c'est comment
par l'aménagement du territoire parce
qu'évidemment
quand vous êtes dans une petite ville où
l'industrie s'en va moi je pense que
c'est mieux si elle reste on peut
continuer à télétravailler pour ce
qu'ils peuvent et ont peu plus grand
pourrait aller à vélo
d'ailleurs mais s'ils essaient souvent
les territoires ruraux je citais la
petite ville enfin une très belle ville
de deux cases ville par exemple saint
claude et une autres fonderies savez
quand le quand ils l'industrie qui
représente le plus gros employeur privé
d'une ville s'en va les habitants s'en
vont je pense que la question de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement d'industries aussi posez
donc il faut faire du sujet le sujet est
donc le maintien du télétravail c'est
une activité dans des centres villes de
taille plus modeste dans des centres
bourgs qui peut permettre ensuite un
aménagement du territoire aujourd'hui
vous avez raison 92,5 sont dans les
métropoles et l'enjeu il est là et vous
avez raison c'est aussi lié à
l'implantation d'emplois sur nos
téléphones les deux il faut les deux
parce que je vous le répète le
télétravail doit être choisi et non pas
imposé moi ça rejoint un peu la question
que j'avais sur l'organisation du
travail
je pense que sur les territoires on voit
bien avec le développement des tirs le
alors que jugera une parenthèse pour les
gens qui nous écoutent
on a bien conscience que tout le monde
ne télétravail pas parce que vers le
présent mandat une discussion et tous
les dix ans
mais là où en tout cas et moi je vous
rejoins sur l'aménagement du territoire
je me demande si dans cette organisation
du travail de demain la place des
entreprises ou des organisations
syndicales naturellement au niveau des
territoires serait pas nécessaire pour
réfléchir à ces tirs lui parce que si on
intègre pas ou est ce qu'on positionne
en tient lieu
c'est un endroit où on peut travailler
qui n'est pas l'entreprise
habituellement qui domine la disposition
pour vous croisez une entreprise
comment bascule parce que enfin il ya
beaucoup de gens qui nous disent aussi
qu'ils n'ont pas forcément envie de
rester tout seul ces jeux pour
télétravailler donc le tiers lui c'est
une sorte d'intermédiaire et moi il me
semble qu'avec les les conseils
économiques régionaux il pourrait y
avoir tout à fait une réflexion
extrêmement intéressante sur le
développement des territoires qui inclut
l'organisation du travail
on se mettrait d'accord entre les
entreprises des organisations syndicales
et les collectifs effectivement il mais
ici on t'offre un tout tout tout doit
être réfléchie mais parce que là didier
baichère il me dit ça peut se faire
ailleurs négociations régionales
mémé yade y a des il ya des débats dans
les dents les conseils économiques
sociaux et environnementaux régionaux au
sein des collectivités il ya si on était
plus reconnu d'ailleurs dans certaines
collectivités où on oublierait panneaux
nos locaux ça ira mieux mais en tout cas
il ya il devrait y avoir des débats mais
à condition tout toutes ces règles
soient transparentes parce que je vois
quand même petit j'entends une petite
musique qui fait qu'il ya des
entreprises pour économiser des loyers
vont aller vont vous demander dans les
collectivités de créer des lieux
qu'elles n'auront pas à prendre en
charge et elles font les économies sur
les loyers donc il faut que tout soit
transparent en fonction de l'activité de
l'entreprise en fonction de la volonté
des salariés c'est c'est plus complexe
que d'ouvrir pourquoi pas des bureaux
partagés dans une collectivité
parce que si je vous le répète si c'est
pour payer moins de loyer supprimer les
trois-quarts de surface qui avait
l'entreprise avant c'est encore les
collectivités qui vont payer à la place
des entreprises je pense que vous n'êtes
pas favorable à ce genre de choses c'est
évidemment pas le message qu'ont
apportés par contre je crois
qu'effectivement le l'emploi qu'ils
soient télétravail à bhl ou pas que ce
soit un emploi en présentiel est un
levier d'aménagement du territoire qui
est sans doute le premier levier qui
permet ensuite de garder les habitants
les services publics les postes les
guichets qui est fait et tout ce qui
s'ensuit est la volonté politique là
dessus est très forte
pour accompagner cette implantation
d'emplois sur l'ensemble du territoire
mais on a là un levier je crois vraiment
avec le télétravail qui permet de
réduire cette fracture territoriale que
kiki qui a nourri
nation j'avais constaté dire que c est
un des leviers mais vous j'espère que
vous n'aurez pas dans vos collectivités
dans vos villes que des gens en
télétravail parce que il faut aussi de
l'activité industrielle l'activité
commerciale vous savez discuté avec le
président des commerçants de la ville de
saint-claude il d'ailleurs quand on a
fait la manifestation il ya quinze jours
il me disait mais c'est une catastrophe
s'il note fonde aussi la fonderie unis
note fonderie ferme
c'est pratiquement un commerçant sur
trois qui va fermer et il me dit
d'ailleurs à l'autre bout de la ville
l'hôpital vient de fermer trois services
et voulait dire ça a été un travail le
remplacera pas évidemment évidemment
didier deschamps voulait aller aussi sur
un autre sujet qui est la diversité dans
la fonction publique ont alors parlé
avec la suppression de l'ena mais ça va
ces autres je voulais les eaux sur autre
chose
oui mais j'étais très surpris en
m'intéressant à ce sujet parce qu'on a
parlé un peu d'emplois privés mais je
conserverai le concours talents aussi de
la fonction publique
finalement on pensait que le rempart aux
inégalités c'était quelque part les
concours en fait qui était qui était
prévu historiquement dans la fonction
publique et quand on regarde les études
je pense en particulier celles qui sont
faites par le cnrs et montre que
malheureusement malgré les concours on
ne continue à avoir une fonction
publique jeudi cette manière générale on
trouverait bien sûr des disparités
importantes d'une fonction publique à
l'eau une fonction publique en fait qui
est pas exactement à l'image de ce
qu'est la france et les discriminations
sont toujours là est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que ce travail qui est
démarrée en essayant de commencer par le
aussi le haut qui n'avait pas été
attaquée avec ces prépas talents qui
vont être mises en place
diversifier les hauts fonctionnaires
pour s'assurer qu'après dans le
recrutement qui seront faits dans les
collectivités il y ait beaucoup plus de
diversité qui soient proposées
moi je pense qu'il faut d'abord agir à
tous les niveaux
lolo c'est un symbole mais c'est quand
on externalise de plus en plus des
métiers des services publics c'est
autant d'emplois soumis à un concours
bien souvent qui disparaissent après le
problème du haut quand vous dites c'est
séquelles accès pour les plus modestes
or de ce point de vue là ça reste
compliqué et puis c'est surtout comment
parce que je pense que c'est ça le fond
du débat autour de la réforme de l'état
c'est parce pas la réforme en tant que
tel c'est comment des hauts
fonctionnaires
je sais pas ce qu'ils apprennent moi
j'ai pas été à l'ena
son nom je sais pas ça pour vous son
plus haut fait de la réalité que vivent
nos citoyens or on voit c'est enfin
c'est comme dans le privé d'ailleurs de
ce point de vue là qu'on a on a des
directives des des notes qui tombait
puis quand on les lit on y habite où ils
ont vécu roues avant et c'est ça qui
fait la fracture est donc et et je crois
pas que ce soit même s'il ya des ddd des
salariés fin des gens de milieux
populaires où je pense que c'est dans la
formation et après dans les tâches
qu'ils ont à faire qu'il faut changer
pas uniquement là il ya une volonté très
claire avec les prépas talent donc de
financer donc pas ce qu'on fait je vous
rejoins il ya un sujet de financements
et de capacité à poursuivre des études
dans les prépas talent donc tu vois de
portée par la majorité des universités
françaises parce qu'on reste dans le
système universitaire c'est aussi une
très bonne nouvelle on va aller chercher
des jeunes qui n'auraient pas pu faire
ceci causeur et on va les financer
c'était moi il me semble là on va
pouvoir bien défini faudrait pas que ça
faudrait pas que les grandes écoles les
déforme cercle ce qu'ils vivaient dans
leur quartier ça va ils seront à
l'université ce qui n'a mais je moi je
suis sérieux la scientifique dans leur
quartier
ce qu'ils ont vécu pendant leur jeunesse
il faudrait pas qu'en arrivant dans les
grandes écoles et je pense que l'ena en
est un symbole il oublie tout ça et
qu'il redescende des choses des notes
des prescriptions et c'est qu'ils sont
complètement en dehors des réalités et
c'est souvent et j'en croise des
énarques par la cgt mais dans des
ministères dans des cabinets et c'est
quand les entends parler on se dit mais
et vous pensez que je dirais évolué au
fil des années parce qu'il ya quand même
maintenant d'informations sur le terrain
des choses comme ça je pense que ça
s'empire
c'est pas mieux moi je suis persuadé en
fait qui est un sujet de recrutement
serre que la formation bien entendu on
est d'accord qu'il faut former expliqué
mais il me semble vraiment que l'origine
du recrutement tant qu'on n'aura pas une
fonction publique qui ressemble à ce
qu'est la france
on aura toujours cette différence oui je
pense que il faut prendre le sujet bien
monde c'est à dire que moi je rencontre
j'ai rencontré il ya quinze jours une
femme à nantes
issu d'un quartier populaire qui m'a dit
mon enfant a huit ans il est dans telle
école dans tel quartier 90 je sais que
c'est fini pour lui
c'est ça qu'on peut pas entendre vous
voyez et c'est là dessus qu'il faut se
battre
et si cet enfant avait la capacité de
faire les plus hautes études et que ça
s'appelait toujours l'ena moi ça ne me
choquerait pas moi ce que je pense et
une vision de l'élitisme mais de
l'élitisme pour tous et c'est ça qu'il
faut porter je pense aujourd'hui c'est
le c'est l'égalité ça s'appelle dans
notre pays c'est à dire que quel que
soit l'endroit où on habite en droit on
a le droit à la même éducation ça veut
dire dont parlait de recrutement de
fauche ou parler de recrutement de
fonctionnaires
quels moyens on donne à l'école pour les
enseignants alors ce qui ce qui est d
enseigner l'éducation mais il ya aussi
la santé oui je voulais vous dire un mot
sur la santé philippe martinez en
prenant un exemple très local mais qui
est je crois assez emblématique de ce
qui se passe au niveau national je
voulais vous dire un mot du chu de
nantes
la maire de nantes vous savez peut-être
a souhaité aménager un nouvel hôpital
pour remplacer le précédent sur ce qu'on
appelle l'île de nantes qui est un site
inadaptée inondable en plein centre
ville en plein centre-ville entre deux
bras de la loire survolée par les avions
bref un site parfaitement inadaptées on
s'est aperçu que pour aménager ce nouvel
hôpital ça allait coûter un milliard
d'euros et pour financer ce projet à un
milliard d'euros
on va supprimer 2 131 lit et 400 emplois
donc ça veut dire que demain les
habitants de la région nantaise
ils auront moins bien en termes d'offre
de soins pour beaucoup plus cher et
pourquoi je vous parle de ça parce que
je crois que c'est très emblématique de
ce qui se passe au niveau national où on
a une santé qui coûte très cher avec un
pourcentage du pib qui est le plus élevé
des pays de l ocde et pourquoi pas sauf
que on a malheureusement un système de
santé qui est pour une part inefficace
la crise sanitaire nous le montre encore
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on peut dire que
les français n'ont pas pour leur argent
j'en compte tenu de l'énergie qui est
mise et des crédits qui sont accordées à
la santé et de l'efficacité de leur
système de santé publique il me semble
qu'une piste pourrait être de réajuster
l'équilibré entre les personnels
administratifs et des personnels
soignants médicaux paramédicaux
c'est à dire moins administratif parce
qu'on a aujourd'hui un administratif
pour deux soignants dans l'hôpital
public français alors c'est beaucoup
plus que partout ailleurs
puis vint alors je l'exemple de nantes
on le retrouve dans tout et attire et
dans toutes les régions dans toutes les
villes pourquoi c'est la course rapide
hospitalier groupement hospitalier de
territoire stark rang avec trois
établissements en fait un
et ça ça fait que bat pour certaines
maternités il faut faire 50 km quand ce
que les à-coups face il ya des problèmes
de grossesse je crois dans un
département en ariège faut faire 200 km
quand 200 km donc on fait on fait un
seul établissement alors qu'ils en
avaient plusieurs de proximité puis on
réduit les effectifs ce cas il ya un
délit mais laurence yadi elle vous dit
est ce qu'il faut pas rire les érotiques
de d'administration pour vous le sentez
le jeu vous est gelée bien l'écouter ou
ce je suis attentif non non parce que
les yeux pers le problème c'est que si
on fait faire puisque les tâches
administratives
il y en a toujours et d'ailleurs ce
qu'il ce dont se plaignent notamment les
infirmières c'est qu'elles ont de plus
en plus de boulot administratif parce
que on a supprimé les emplois et que
leur boulot à elle c'est de soigner les
gens pas de rentrée des machins des
trucs donc je pense qu'il faut mais le
vrai débat c'est est ce que la santé
c'est une dépense ou un investissement
moi je pense que c'est un investissement
donc par exemple s'il ya une formule qui
va bien à la santé c'est le quoi qu'il
en coûte
parce que soigner des gens sauver les
vies ce n'est pas une dépense et en
investissant philippe martinez que vous
me poser comme question avant après il
ya quelques énarques qui disent bas ont
fait une statistique qui attendent
habitants dans ce territoire la
proportion
sans mettre d'accord sur un constat qui
est que pour les crédits extrêmement
important que les français consacrent à
leur santé publique
on a des résultats qui sont largement
plus inefficace qu'ailleurs et le sujet
c'est comment est-ce qu'on règle cette
contradiction
on a les deux en fait ce constat mais
c'est pas moi qu'il fait c'est les
soignants encore comment vous le régler
il faut mieux orienter les l'argent
petit vin l'hôpital vous dites qu'on ait
pas beaucoup d'argent mais eu beaucoup
d'exonérations de cotisations j'en
parlais tout à l'heure les cotisations
sociales ses pour la santé et il faut
embaucher il faut embaucher et que le
personnel soignant il soit y soigne et
qu'il au personnel administratif
il aide le personnel soignant il faut
recréer il faut ré ouvrir des services
voire mais contient la salpêtrière dans
la période
on ne sait pas s'ils l'ont fait ils
voulaient fermer le réfectoire des
soignants pour y installer des lits de
réanimation non mais vous rendez compte
alors qu'à côté pas loin il ya un
hôpital qui est fermé en hôpital
militaire
voilà des choses très concrètes il est
l'heure maintenant de faire un détour
par le figaro live nous attend vincent
roux jean soir vincent
vous allez me dire ce que les
internautes vos lecteurs et nos
téléspectateurs ont retenu de
l'actualité aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de
blocages des lycées ce qui bloque
réclament l'annulation du grand oral du
bac
cette épreuve imaginé par jean michel
blanquer air et de l'épreuve de philo la
seule qui doit ce qui doit se tenir qui
échappe au contrôle continu
ils réclament eux que tout passe en
contrôle continu
est ce que c'est votre avis philippe
martinez août et ça fait très longtemps
que j'ai passé mon bac et donc je pense
qu'il faut certainement écouté les
élèves curieux beaucoup de difficultés
même en télétravail pour mais j'avoue
que sur la question n'est un bac en
continu ça vous choque pas vous parce
que certains disent ça dévalorise alors
sur le bas contre continue là c'est très
ponctuel
la question qui est posée parce que
celui-ci allait attendre non il faut il
faut ceux qui contestent le bac contre
continue je pense qu'ils ont raison
c'est qu'il faut une même les mêmes
chances pour tout le monde peut d'avoir
un diplôme qui correspond parce que
quand on va quand on est 35 élèves par
classe dans un certain nombre de lycées
de banlieue
eh bien on est l'enseignement il est
différent même en continu que dans des
lycées on est 20 par classe donc là
aussi pour avoir des points instants
pour avoir les mêmes chances il faut que
la règle soit la même pour tout le monde
face à philippe martinez je ne me piquer
mes relances en importance a répondu
qu'il avait alors moi j'ai une question
à vous poser ce que vous avez un masque
depuis le début des auditions qui
s'appelle culture en danger
alors on sait qu'il ya encore des
dizaines de théâtre occupé en france
avec des intermittents qui s'inquiètent
pour leur avenir intermittence et un
statut n'est pas un métier ils sont
d'abord avec c'est cathy siens avec le
statut d'intermittent
est ce que vous demandez que l'année
blanche soit reporté comme ça a été
effectivement effectivement parce qu'ils
font partie des professions qui ont le
plus souffert vous demandez quoi précisé
mathieu que cette année blanche soit
reconduite encore un an le temps que la
situation se sa melior parce que pour
l'instant eux ne travaillent toujours
pas fait les échéances arrivent arrive
didier baichère et laurence garnier nous
reste un tout petit peu ton juste très
rapidement vous comment en 12 secondes
vous voyez ce déconfinement parce qu on
avoue commencer l'émission avec avec ça
est ce que vous y voyez quand même des
raisons d'espérer ou est-ce que vous
êtes inquiet en dix ans toutes les
précautions n'ont pas été prises
rapidement annoncer une raison d'espérer
c'est une renommée c'est vraiment
l'occasion que le pays repart et c'est
maintenant qu'il faut le faire je pense
que les conditions sanitaires elles sont
aux maîtrises et il y aura des
protocoles et ce que ce soit pour la
culture que ce soit pour les restos
l'éducation vous attend dans l'éducation
bien sûr mais mais c'est important je
prends le bac on continue sa série la
question des idées des lycéens afin de
qui sont interminables montre aussi
comment au bout d'un an finalement on
commence à voir des raisonnements qui me
peuvent être inquiétant et pourquoi on
voulait maintenir l'école absolument
ouverte c'est aussi pour cette raison se
dire que le bac aisément que des jeunes
à l'école le bac est déjà très largement
contre le continue donc tout d'un coup
il ya une forme d'habituation à être à
la maison a pas se confronter à la
réalité de son examen et moi ça
m'inquiète un petit peu regardé en deux
mots c'est un pari politique c'est un
pari politique parce que c'est autour de
nous et nos voisins rouvrent leurs
restaurants leurs musées progressivement
c'est un pari politique je n'ai qu'une
envie comme tous les français c'est d'y
croire pour l'éducation pour les jeunes
pour la culture mais ça reste un pari
politique risqué
merci didier baichère merci merci et
vous pour audition publique audition
publique qui revient en direct lundi à
19h30 merci bonne soirée
[Musique]
cette émission a été enregistrée avant
l'obligation du port du masque public
sénat avec le soutien de mutualia la
mutuelle d'été
[Musique]